We're here in the Land of Fire and Ice...
...to see some of the filming locations for the Game of Thrones.
"Winter is coming, embrace yourselves!"
We are at Nesjavellir.
This is where the great battle between Brienne of Tarth and the Hound took place.
This, where the people are walking, is the pathway to the Eyrie.
That's where the Bloody Gate is.
I'm actually going to show you a waterfall.
After the Hound is dead, Arya rides away on her pony,...
...and is by the Icelandic waterfall, Hjalparfoss.
The Wildlings come attacking from the forest on the other side of the house,...
...and then they take Olly, and they grab Olly by the head and say,...
..."I'm going to eat your dead mama and papa.
Go tell the crows at Castle Black."
Our guide was very enthusiastic,...
...pointing out bits of scenery where action took place,...
...and it was a thoroughly enjoyable day.
Whether you're a huge Game of Thrones fan or not,...
...this tour is extremely enjoyable.
Our guide is funny, knowledgeable and passionate,...
...and it's an incredibly fun way to enjoy your day in Iceland.